hey this is the first video I'm going to
be doing for the channel it's about
range of motion and how to increase your
range of motion
so a few things to mention first
obviously having good range of motion is
incredibly important in any kind of
sport to prevent injuries and be able to
move better by having that fluidity of
movement you're gonna be much more
spontaneous so you don't want to only be
able to throw one kind of technique from
a certain position but I think
especially in terms of martial arts what
people tend to lack is they'll focus
upon the lower flexibility because it's
obvious you need that to be able to
perform high kicks and things like that
but if they've neglected other things
like lower back for instance and upper
flexibility then that can really inhibit
how you move further down the line
especially for doing things like
spinning kicks in which you need to be
really loose to be able to throw them
quickly
so while obviously having a good level
of flexibility is really important so
that you don't get injured and you're
able to perform well don't let anybody
tell you that you need to be able to
perform splits to be able to do good
kicks with good technique because you
don't because of my big legs and karate
I can do the splits not frog so we've
all seen those martial arts guys who've
got incredible flexibility and can you
know do things like over splits on
blocks and all that sort of stuff and
they can put the leg up and hold it in
the air and everything but they've got
no power or no snap or no intention
should I say behind any of their moves
[Music]
and then you've got the guys in the
other hand who focused only on power and
neglected to become flexible and all
they can do is kind of like charge
forward with force which you don't want
either oh great so it's about having a
nice balance you want to be able to be
flexible enough to perform the moves you
want but then also have the muscle
strength to be able to deliver power
behind the attacks so the different
types of flexibility that were going to
be focusing on here
are dynamic flexible 'ti and static
flexibility dynamic flexibility is
basically where you move a joint through
its kind of entire range of motion or
work up towards doing that I find it
gets you really really loose and then
you can kick much more fluidly and you
can also stay much more relaxed which is
super important for developing speed as
well in static flexibility or stretching
is basically where you hold a muscle in
an uncomfortable but variable position
for a period of time say ten to thirty
seconds is usually the recommended
amount dynamic stretching is to be done
before a training session and static
stretching is to be done after a
training session when you're nice and
warm or you can do it later on some
people do it after having a warm bath so
that their muscles are nice and loose as
well I find it astonishing the amount of
people who are considered high level
martial arts instructors who kind of
really should know better who prescribed
static stretching before an intense
workout if you do that it can actually
make your muscles to relax to remember
me talk about those neurological
safeguards and you can accidentally go
beyond your limits and injure yourself
and you can also get things like
tendinitis as well I've heard from doing
it
I personally do static stretching in the
evening times I don't really find it
beneficial to do it after training and I
never ever get injured the only time
I've ever got injured like I said before
is when our neglected state stretching
all together and then when indeed
full-force kicks and I've got pulled
groin by doing that which is really
annoying because you can't train
properly for ages and it takes a long
time to heal so make sure you don't
neglect your static stretching at the
right times though the reason that we do
after stretch is because we have these
safeguards that are built into our brain
that activate the counter muscle
antagonists when the muscle of
stretching is getting close to reaching
its maximum range of motion this is
obviously to prevent injury so that we
don't just do something way beyond our
normal range of motion and pull a muscle
it's more about relaxing into the
movement slowly over time and with
consistency to be able to get to that
maximum range of motion I will tell you
that I find stretching incredibly boring
and if something I never really like to
do but I kind of forced myself to do it
through just discipline basically I like
to be moving quickly and doing dynamic
things so I find stretching quite boring
just to sit down and not really do much
that leads me to my next point which is
that it's super important to also
maintain a level of flexibility
throughout your sport inactivity
training whatever you're doing if you're
training in something and you kind of
really familiar with the type of
technique it can actually be way more
dangerous if you live like flexibility
from that point that's because you can
almost force yourself into that position
regardless of what your muscle
antagonist is saying I've done this
before because like I say add it really
like to stretch and because I'm used to
doing the certain types of techniques I
can kind of force my body into those
positions and past those safeguards so
you want to be really careful with that
so now we're gonna go to some footage of
me warming up in the gym a little bit so
as you can see here firstly and just
move my feet around doing some kind of
little crisscross motions with my feet
just to warm up my legs and get a bit of
a sweat on one of the ankles or things
like that so next I will warm up by
doing some basic kind of footwork and
shift in a little bit your Center is
here I am doing these direction changes
which is a really good way of activating
your core I find if you're gonna do
these make sure that your core is nice
and tight and your body's all shifting
as one unit so your legs aren't leaving
behind your upper body it's really good
for your legs and it loves to teach you
to be nice and loose while also moving
quickly this is also quite good for your
coordination and speed as well so after
I'm a little bit warmed up I will start
to do the actual dynamic stretches what
I'm basically doing is swinging my arm
in a figure of eight pattern try to keep
your shoulders quite straight and just
let the arms swing loosely I find enough
to do this that I feel a lot more fluid
when I move so this one's really similar
to the other one if you notice how I'm
swinging my arms round again in big
circles nice and loose in the figure of
eight my body moved a little bit more
with my arm for this one you want to try
to keep your shoulders square and just
let the arm through the word holding up
the hand off nice and straight will
stabilise you a little bit with that as
well so this next one I'm doing here is
a little bit more like an active stretch
it doesn't look like much but it really
really opens up the hips if you do it
correctly the main thing that you want
to watch out for and if you can notice
from these clips here is the way I keep
my body at the same level throughout the
movement if you manage to do that you'll
really feel an opening of the hips as
you pass through that central point so
we're moving on to the actual dynamic
leg swings now that I spoke about
earlier
these are the front leg swings I stand
in a really generic sort of stance and
then I take the back leg and swing it up
straight as high as it can go and also
pull the toes of the swinging leg back
as well for an extra stretch on the calf
try to keep your hips square and avoid
the tendency to lay your body down
against the lake these next ones are
very similar but they're more of a
crescent kick variation going in more of
an insight to outside circular motion
these will open up your hip a little bit
more and create
good Square from flexibility so now
we're gonna move on to the real X words
if you notice here I'm actually using
the wall in front of me as assistance to
balance this is actually a little bit
high for my height foot and you want to
try to lean on something like a wall or
a ledge just above where your waist
height is so we want to do with these is
take the kicking leg and if you notice
how I put it's slightly more in front of
me before us wait that's just to gain a
little bit of momentum and it helps the
leg to go up a little bit higher as well
if you noticed here I'll do my best to
keep my body completely square the
tendency for your hips here is to open
out slightly and become while return to
hip position but you want to try to keep
your body as square as possible because
we're targeting a different muscle for
this stretch all right now moving on to
the psyche variation make sure that the
standing foot is facing towards the wall
or the thing that you're leaning on so
it'll be basically that your heel is
facing towards your kicking target
however this time as to swing the leg up
I'm gonna look towards the kick as a
would in a psyche position and I'm gonna
swing the leg up with my hips turned the
most common error I see people make that
this is allowing their toes of their
kicking foot to go higher than their
heel now if that happens it actually
becomes more like a front swing instead
of a side swing and be losing the
benefit of this type of stretch there
basically after doing these dynamic
stretches what I usually like to do is
just go and loosely play around doing
some light kicks on the back and playing
around with a little bit of footwork
it's nothing too serious we're not
trying to apply power we're just getting
used to moving and loosening off the
body I would find that when I do this it
doesn't seem like I'm doing much but
when I actually come to kick in hard or
hitting hard later
I always feel a lot better and like I'm
able to apply my energy much better so I
usually probably will do this for three
to five minutes but sometimes if I get
into it I'll stay doing this for like
ten to fifteen minutes just playing
around with different things
and havin fun with it again i SaLuSa
yeah okay so now moving on to the static
stretch in as you can see I've done some
training and ice and sweaty and this is
a good time to do static stretching
because your muscles are nice and loose
they've just been used now this first
stretch is the butterfly stretch I like
to say again something when I'm doing
this that's because I find that if I
don't sit against him - my body tends to
slide out and I lose the alignment what
you want to do is get your feet to touch
each other and bring them as close into
your pelvis as possible if you're not
that flexible already you probably won't
be able to get your legs in that far I
like to usually grab my ankles and pull
them in to make sure they're aligned
remember static stretching is supposed
to be uncomfortable but not painful so
don't push too hard and injure yourself
the next one is a classic Bock split
stretch if you notice here I'm wearing
these socks and that's because I find it
way easier to slide down and get into
the right position if you notice here I
go down into it in a certain way which
isn't exactly in the alignment of the
stretch and then when I feel I'm at my
maximum position
I will slightly shift my weight forwards
to make sure that my body is nice and
aligned and straight enough people flat
it onto the ground
a common error with this one that you
want to watch out for is the abort
doesn't go back and too far out of
alignment it's okay to go down into the
shape and then shift afterwards so make
sure that you get into a straight line
you can do this yourself at home by
having a mirror placed at your side
getting into position and they're
looking into the nerves to see if your
hips are aligned so those are a couple
of static stretches that you can do and
in future videos I'll be able to go into
much greater detail and shapes and much
more in depth stretching as well and
finally these are a couple of yoga style
stretches that are do these can either
work after the main static stretching
part or you can do it before because
they're not like stressful on your
muscles so if you notice here I'm in a
kind of elongated walking stance this is
really good for stretching the hip
flexor which is something that gets
really really used
click it I'll take one of my hands and
place it down on the ground it doesn't
matter which one because you want to do
this both ways and I'll take the other
hand and I'll stick it up in the sky or
stretch my fingers out we want to try to
keep your body as straight and aligned
as possible during this so imagine that
your chest is sandwiched between two
panes of glass that aren't too far apart
from each other and this stretch is
really good for front flexibility
stretching hamstrings as well as the
calves when I tried to keep both legs as
straight as you can on this one you
notice here our I lean my body down to
the leg but I'm using my chest to lead
not actually with my head because if you
just bend at the neck it can appear like
you're really leaning down the mat leg
but you're actually not because there's
a big gap between your head and your
chest and there's a lot more of this
stretch that you could actually do if
you are correctly aligned if you liked
this video and found value in it please
subscribe to the Baniya and follow me
across all social media platforms thank
you very much for watching and I'll see
you next time